nevada simply does not have the dollars
the monetary resources in order to set
up plans
like some of the other states do i'm not
satisfied but i'm proud of everything
that our frontline workers have done
well earlier tonight the governor just
tossed out the playbook when it comes to
the kobit 19 vaccine ditching tears
for lanes now the idea is to get more
nevadans vaccinated faster
now one lane includes frontline and
essential workers and the other is made
up of the general public
it also shows that not everyone within
an age group is going to be vaccinated
together
it can really depend on overall health
and underlying factors
it's also clear priority falls to those
who must work in person
versus those who can work from home now
still topping both of those lanes
front line workers and nevadans who are
70 years and older
rounding out the bottom are healthy
adults ages 16 to 64.
we are moving away from a tiered
structure to focus on
lanes of vaccination that will run
concurrently
this changes the structure of our
playbook and plan going forward
but does not impact the counties already
moving into what was previously
identified
as tier two